but before I hate it I hate that people
think that like I should be dating
somebody else the haters and I'm not
when I look at kalila I think she's
lucky to be dating me I think no one I
feel that way I don't think for one
second like oh you know people were
equally as I'm blessed we make a good
team
mm-hmm I wouldn't have 70 percent of the
things I have right now without her I'm
being real this is the honest truth the
directory to trajector how do you say
the directory true [ __ ] I'm gonna say
it
tragic trajector Jack Project Tory
trajectory the trajectory trajectory of
my life
is the way it is because of kalila
foundation because no it's not it's even
little things like when I you know a
couple years ago you know I was outside
this audition I wasn't gonna go in and
she basically called me a [ __ ] for not
going in there and I went in there and I
booked the pilot because of her this
podcast you should do one I don't want
to do one I no one's gonna care she goes
you know what I'm gonna buy the
equipment anyway
she did that you know all these things
and all the things that are happening in
my career has a lot to do with kalila in
my life you know I I also I hated
animals I used to put bunny rabbits in
the microwave like I don't give a [ __ ]
bro and she introduced me to my [ __ ]
kids
gunner Ming Bobby jr. and Gobi and
they're they're the light of my life I
wouldn't give me that much credit I
think I just added a little bit of
organization in your life a little bit
of structure which is what you really
desperately I had girlfriends before ago
let's get a dog
go [ __ ] yourself I'll eat it I'm being
real
I'll [ __ ] eat it mmm I think okay we
won't get one right with her we she had
a it was because of me
she had a kitten when I dated a first
day that her name Ming who lives in my
house now mm-hmm and I was at her house
in Long Beach it was like the first
night I was spending in that our house
we hadn't had sex yet
and Ming was on my shoulder sleeping she
was like a little black and white fur
ball and she was on my shoulders and I
call I'm gonna squeeze it I want to
squeeze this until the [ __ ] eyes pop
out of it she says no you didn't I
didn't I didn't do it but you don't want
I want to get this book seized you know
it's true I've written about this before
and you know and like my diary I'm like
I'm pretty sure you know he's only
pretending to like cats cuz he wants to
get inside me right cuz I don't think
that he genuinely liked them at that
time then one day she goes I don't know
she was going out of town or something
but she goes can Ming stay at your house
and and can you take care of Ming and I
go you know I'm seeing this girl I like
I like her a lot I'm gonna do it and one
day being is I'm just sitting there
watching TV or playing video games and
being just looks at me and she goes hi
whoa
right she welcome to research purring
and I cut it and then we lock eyes and I
bonded to it and I go I like this little
girl and she became a friend I'm gonna
love her
nothing sexual but like I loved I loved
her and then I go Ming needs
I love me so much she needs a friend so
we got cooter mm-hmm we went to the
[ __ ] place the OSH woods for [ __ ]
animals was called Pasadena Humane
Society call it that's the other name
right yeah and I remember what I saw
guter in the cage and he wasn't the
cutest one
but I remember good her you know he was
a kitten and he got his knees he walked
up to the thing and he put his head to
the side and he goes oh yeah like that
and I go that's it
goodness the best
and then we got papi jr. I know babe I'm
just doing come on Dave I dated for
dramas good anticipation and then your
fireman buddy because we found a kitten
it's gonna die we're doing how small it
was
oh yeah it had bear he had barely opened
his eyes yeah we brought that [ __ ] on
we breastfed no way your breath for you
we present what do we do we fed it every
milk every time from a bar from a nipple
I try to put my nipple of nothing I'm
hey I fed her puss for and that little
guy grew up and that little guy used to
hate me he didn't like me it doesn't
matter
unconditional love is what they call it
I gave an unconditional love and now
when I play video games fallout 4 right
now it just sleeps on my [ __ ] I might
you know they're just all around him all
the wrong recaps and a dog and then the
dog came into my life and I'm like you
know what this is my future this is the
trajectory of my life and I'm gonna open
up an animal sanctuary one day mm-hmm
that's our plan that's our plan and I'm
gonna harbor animals home and the sick
ones we're going to still love it we're
not gonna try to nurse it but we'll
legally put it to sleep and then we'll
eat them yeah yeah that's what they do
like in the [ __ ] I call them [ __ ] the
guns and the Philippines like in the
Octagon you know and there's like
cockfighting whoever the losing chicken
is what they used to like mop up the
blood of Octagon but then they always
eat the chicken that chicken then goes
to the winner the the winning chicken's
owner and then they barbecue it outside
so there's a barbecue outside stop come
to the Philippines stop yeah I think I
completely misunderstood what you're
saying so let me just say think what
this is whatever you're saying yeah two
[ __ ] are fighting chickens the one that
loses yeah does that mean they're dead
they're dead you think yeah because they
have so some [ __ ] takes the carcass
of the guy that died
oh yeah and then wipes the [ __ ] arena
the blood arena with it the body it's
what I grew up watching I mean this is
just what you see when you grow up in a
country like that and yeah but then they
just we eat it afterwards you eat it
afterwards what is it what happens is
the winner the winner then it goes home
no usually no because they've been
injured to some extent like at least my
cousins chickens they get to rest and
you know it's really a [ __ ] up life
they live because they have to be in
isolation to build that type of
aggression yeah these guys are leaving
now
I guess I got
[Music]